okay some of the popular images from my
Instagram account from the last week I
am on instagram at david pakman I posted
Pat a picture on a pseudo snow day we
still did a show but it was a it was a
very snowy day a picture of me drinking
tea out of my university of
massachusetts alumni mug and i started
getting hammered by people saying i have
been corrupted by the alumni marketing
industrial complex involving all sorts
of alumni products I want to say very
clearly right now the UMass alumni mug
is the only thing I have in terms of
alumni products and I didn't buy it it
was given to me as a gift when I spoke
at UMass at an economics panel so I
really am not part of the alumni
products industrial complex which
involves everything from t-shirts and
sweatshirts to bumper stickers mugs and
of course calling you and asking for
donations to to your old school so I am
defending myself from that allegation
well my takeaway is you can have your
life documented by coffee mugs now
because we now have the david pakman
show coffee mug I don't know what else
you can get but yeah you know to have a
couple more I think then you have a
timeline so anyway listen it's just a
mug in the end it is just a tea mug or a
tea or coffee mug and that's really it
so I didn't didn't really think that the
hubub was worth it also I posted a hate
mail or a hate facebook message that we
received from someone named Jacob which
said just you're a joke but of course
it's why oh you are so to me meaning
like my a joke the a joke that belongs
to me as opposed to David is a joke and
we responded as we sometimes do with
just your y ou you apostrophe re this is
definitely by far the most common
mistake that we see in hate mail right
Oh as yoe war instead of y.o.u
apostrophe re you gotta love it too
because you have to help him make his
own argument because he's just too
enough to do so yeah referencing my a
joke is not really an insult
let me help you to tell me that your
opinion is that i am a joke which of
course I reject unilaterally it's
possible he was talking about the joke
that you own but he put in a there which
wouldn't really make sense and he left
out the rest of the sentence if it was
just your joke then I would say oh yeah
this is a this is and actually this is
about a joke that I must have told at
some point but clearly that's not what
this person then follow me on instagram
david pakman a lot of high jinks on
there and people enjoying it that's
that's what i read these days the kids
are all over instagram and snapchat and
and and all that stuff you're not on
snapchat are you i am on snapchat are
you really yeah you're on snapchat yes
okay well we'll edit that out i don't
think you want people failing that